I have never had ramen before I didn't
know until two days ago that there was
such a thing as restaurant ramen because
I was vegetarian I never had experience
with ramen because had animal
by-products I'm expecting you know slimy
noodles and soup that's too salty I'm
hopeful I'm a little bit nervous I have
a Vietnamese [ __ ] I begged I boat
noodles my name is social autonomy I'm a
store manager of early onset noodle I'm
very excited for you guys to try the
ramen for the first time
here we go ramen thank you I think I
smelled seaweed yeah
gross it doesn't look anything like I
was expecting it looks eclectic hearty
and eclectic mm-hmm I'm splashing
holding myself but not a deep food it's
a little salty it's not too salty I
taste like chicken noodle soup it's like
if gravy was like mixed with the chicken
broth and kind of watered down a little
bit that is really good pork pork isn't
my favorite thing there's a slimy thing
going on juicy it's salty it's all the
good stuff I've never seen a brown egg I
don't think I've ever had a whole egg
since I was probably a small child I'm a
fan I'm a fan of the egg like passable
actually the after case or whatever it
is it gets a little bit better as you
eat it it's good it's definitely growing
on me I'm gonna have to order stuff
that's not sushi when I go to Japanese
places now yeah the more I eat it the
bad hair days
that's so weird this is like if you
added a Japanese twist to Thanksgiving
now by the end especially with that egg
I'm like I'm a fan incident Rama's got
nothing on this this is like legit but
I'm not a full-blown
believer I feel like I should have been
introduced to this a long time ago
college students should not be given the
45 cent plastic bread rafts whatever
that is this is what I want when it's
raining the books I want some ramen
[Music]